STEPHANIE WONG: Business agility
is about consuming services
and applications.
With more and more SaaS and
services being consumed,
you don't have to reinvent
the wheel to be productive.
Google Cloud Private
Service Connect
is the solution to
help you accelerate
your consumption of these
services in the Cloud
securely, simply, and quickly.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Services like ERP SaaS
applications, database
as a service, financial data
sets, log analytics, and file
sharing have increasingly
enabled companies
to stay ahead.
That trend and the
migration to Cloud
will only continue
for enterprises.
But diverse services
means more complexity.
Services all live in different
networks and environments.
Application developers want to
simply connect to and consume
each service, rather
than spend time tinkering
with routing tables, IP
addresses, and NAT rules.
In addition, security
has only become
more fundamental to all
aspects of company operations.
Most companies have
requirements to restrict traffic
to private networks,
not allowing public IPs
in order to reduce
vulnerabilities.
Google Cloud Private
Service Connect
vastly simplifies
service connectivity
so you can consume
services quickly
with minimal management.
It's a fully-managed solution.
It lets you setup private
connectivity to your own,
third-party, and Google
services across networks
that belong to different
groups, teams, projects,
or organizations.
If you're trying to set up
connectivity for a workload
to consume data from
services like a GKE
private master,
Cloud Spanner, Cloud
Storage, or a financial
dataset on a private network,
PSC lets you simply set up
an endpoint from your network
and a target service.
If you want to expose a
service like a log streaming
application to be
discoverable, you simply
set up a service attachment.
Private Service Connect enables
service-centric networking
by creating an
abstraction layer on top
of our traditional
network capabilities
to make the network
completely transparent.
It helps you consume
services faster,
achieve a service-driven
environment, secure your data,
and simplify network management.
Private Service
Connect is secure.
Traffic doesn't traverse
a public internet.
Your services
interact like they're
on their own private network.
Simple and performant.
It takes care of
network configuration,
so you don't have to
worry about routing
tables, IP addresses, and
unnecessary coordination
between teams.
You don't need to configure
proxies in your network
and it provides
line-rate performance.
Agile.
It lets you focus
on the service,
instead of network
management, so dev teams
are empowered to easily
set up connectivity
on their own, unburdening
network engineering teams.
Both teams can independently
get up and running
and be more productive.
For the demo today, I already
created all the networking
resources, instances,
internal load balancer,
and Cloud Storage
bucket represented
in this diagram for simplicity.
We're going to show how a
client in the consumer VPC
can access a new service
in the producer VPC
through a private Service
Connect endpoint and service
attachment.
When the client sends
traffic from its source IP
to the endpoint, the
Private Service Connect
will send the allowed
traffic from the client IP
to another address in
the producer subnet
where the Private Service
Connect service attachment is,
then to the internal
load balancer forwarding
rule to forward traffic
to the backend servers.
I'll then show the client
also accessing a Google API--
a Cloud Storage bucket--
through another Private
Service Connect endpoint.
I'll start with the producer
VPC with two subnets.
10.0.2 is the producer subnet
that hosts our web servers,
then the PSC subnet gives
access from the consumer
network to producer
services being exposed.
To show you the
routes, I can verify
that there is no connectivity
from the consumer VPC
to the producer VPC, just a
default route to the internet.
I only have firewall rules that
allow traffic from those two
subnets, plus the
health check ranges
to make sure my
service is healthy.
If I head over to Private
Service Connect and then
the Publish Services tab, I can
see the psc-producer service.
It's configured to automatically
accept all projects,
and staging-web is my consumer
project already connected.
This exposed service
is the load balancer
as a backend with a
private IP of 10.0.2.10,
and in frontends, our web
server instances, which
is the service we're exposing.
Now I'll show my consumer
VPC with a single subnet
and different private IP.
And I also have no
firewall rules setup here
on the consumer side.
Under Routes, there's
nothing but the subnet route.
I deleted the default
route to the internet
to show Private Service
Connect enabling connection
to Google APIs--
in this case, our
storage bucket.
Under Private
Service Connect, you
can see here there's
two connected endpoints.
The psc-consumer endpoint
targets the web servers
we have on the producer VPC.
This endpoint ends in .100.
The pscga endpoint
targets all Google APIs.
This endpoint ends in .111.
When the pscga
endpoint was created,
it also created a
new DNS private zone
with DNS name p.googleapis.com.
It doesn't create any
records, but you can now
use Private Service
Connect to target
Google APIs using
this domain and you
get automatic DNS resolution.
Next, I'll navigate to
the consumer-client VM
with only an
internal IP and I'll
SSH into it using Cloud Shell.
To show the client using
Private Service Connect to reach
the web servers in
the producer VPC,
I'll run a curl command
to the web server
in the producer VPC subnet
using its local endpoint
ending in .100.
And I can see I can
access the server.
Now let's provide
connectivity to Google APIs
with Private Service Connect.
I can query our storage bucket
using the Private Service
Connect endpoint-- pscga--
by doing an nslookup
for storage-
the PSC endpoint name
.p.googleapis.com.
And it returns the pscga
endpoint IP, 100.111.
I also have my gsutil
client configured
to use this private
endpoint, and now I
can list the bucket content.
Just to prove that's the
content, if I navigate
to the consumer-psc-bucket
page in the Console,
it's the same file.
Going back to the consumer
VPC's Firewall Rules page,
you can see the psc-subnet
rule now has a hit count of 1,
because the session
I just established.
The connectivity
between the client VM,
and producer backends, and the
storage bucket isn't explicit,
but it's enabled by
Private Service Connect.
It happens privately
and securely
through Google's
backbone network.
With Private
Service Connect, you
can consume services faster
and stay ahead of the curve
because it's a
fully-managed solution,
meet compliance and keep traffic
secure, simplify your network
and move to the Cloud faster,
leverage a strong and growing
list of third-party
vendors and partners,
and get performance
and scale to keep up
with your growth
and the competition.
Check out
cloud.google.com/private
service connect to learn more,
and check out the links below
for code labs and guide.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]